[Music]
let's go to
marie in cleveland ohio what's up marie
how we doing
i'm great thank you so much for taking
my call are you a baker mayfield fan
a what
a baker mayfield fan
i don't i don't know what that is
listen
i'm married but i kind of love you i'm
glad you don't know who that is that's
the quarterback of the cleveland browns
oh not a huge fan so good for uh
shout out shout out way to go marie
i don't know any like sports references
at all and that makes you a great person
all right so what's up how can i help um
thank you thank you just amazing to be
able to talk to you so thank you so much
it is more amazing to be talking to you
so what's up we the past month and a
half i've been listening to your show
and it's just been mind-blowing how
amazing it's been for me so wow thank
you so much um so my sister uh we are
um the two oldest of five kids and she
is my uh she's two years older than me
and she is not
my biological sister
yeah we have different dads
and she does not know it
how does she not know
um so
my mom um met my dad and i think she was
only
maybe a month or two pregnant
and then they got married um that next
summer um a month after my sister was
born
and
i've know i've known for about 10 years
my mom told me when i was in my early
20s and
she just
she never told her
and
family knows even some close friends
know
god why would your mom do that to you
i don't
i don't know i think that she felt that
i was probably mature enough to be able
to handle it oh my gosh this is the
worst to be
gosh
this is the meanest thing
that's so mean is your does your does
your dad know
that yes
so your sweet sister is just bee-bopping
through life hugging on dad and
everybody knows
but her
yes
my mom told me i cried and she's like
why are you crying and i said i'm just
thinking that if you just were you
telling me about this about me i thought
i would be heartbroken
yes and did you do my first question
would have been was dad my dad
yeah and then she would have said well
of course honey and then you would have
said
how do i how do i
trust anything is santa claus real
you're gonna tell me that too
god almighty what an evil thing to do to
a young 20 year old sister so
you've are you close with your older
sister
so no um
it's getting a little bit better but
i've recently been in counseling
and counseling has uh basically unveiled
my childhood to me
um i um
i thought that i was this
super mature and
helpful and
um
the golden child basically is kind of my
childhood when i was actually as my
counselor called it a parentified child
and um my sister was defiant and she was
hard and it was it was really
it was really really difficult okay can
i give you some context for that yes
i would be willing to bet
my
truck and let's be clear it's not nice
so it's not a huge win if anybody picks
up the other side of that bet
your sister was not wanted in this new
marriage
she was a daily reminder to a newlywed
couple
that mom slept with some other dude and
got knocked up
and your dad
as part of the deal had to raise
somebody else's daughter and all of that
stress and all of that stuff
and your sister absorbed every second of
it
i
is that fair
it's hard
it's hard for me to have a compassion
a clear understanding because i
obviously did not understand my
childhood very well while i was going
through it
um and
so
i
saw my dad as a wonderful dad
and somebody who took care of his family
and and loved my mom and loved my sister
so
i don't want to think of them as
being malicious towards my sister in any
kind of way i don't think i don't i
don't think malicious is the right way
okay i've
the research on adhd right now says a
lot of that begins in utero with
maternal stress
just finding out i'm pregnant and i
had a one night stand with somebody and
i love this new guy and is he gonna love
me and how am i gonna have this baby and
will you
all that stuff
just pulses through this human being
and even if
so your description of your dad is
i'm assuming i'm not let's talk bad
about him i'm just talking reality
yeah you were his baby
you were the one
you were his firstborn
and i'm not saying he's worse he did a
noble thing he's probably an incredible
dad loved
but there is a gap there is a difference
it's kind of like i walk into a room i'm
a big guy
i'm 6'2 195 i'm a big guy i walk into a
room and i'm like everybody's cool here
and then my friend george is like how
big is george 411 102 he's a little guy
he experiences that room differently
than me
yeah and i can be like no dude it's just
like this can you not see
and he's like yeah you're two feet
taller your
your view is different
both of our realities are true
but i i want to always lean over and say
lean in lean over that's funny he is
short but i want to lean into
like what is your reality here's mine
all i have to say is i don't want to get
into your sister situation um other than
i'm glad glad glad you got in you're
seeing somebody
and let that be about illumination not
about blame is that fair
yes okay cool
okay so i just don't know if i should
if it's been i've known for like i think
it's been at least 10 years and my and
now my younger brothers they know and i
just don't
okay this makes it a little more
complicated so she had three children
and my parents are raising two of them
and my husband and i are raising her
third child we've had him from the
moment he was born we brought him home
from the hospital we were there for his
birth and
the reason the whole should i tell her
comes up is because my son will know
i'm going to be 100 honest with him and
we're going to have trust and we're
going to have
you know clarity about who he is
and
i just can see him one day telling my
sister well no you know he's not
actually my biological grandfather and
they're blowing up my sister's world
so let me be super clear your sister's
world has been blown up
it has been blown up since the day she
came home and was told that somebody
else was her dad
yeah
every bit of it has been blown up
and so the only thing left to do
is to help with the healing process
let me put it this way this
conversation's happening
whether it happens today or in five
years or in 10 years it's happening
yes and the
let me let me just tell you personally i
will not keep immediate secrets for
family
so if anybody in my family were to call
and say hey i just got to tell you this
don't tell i was to stop him and say i'm
not good i'm not going to hear that i
don't know what you're about to say but
i'm not keeping secrets from my family
i'm not going to be the big secret
keeper because it kills me
it puts my integrity on the line you
hand me one of your bricks and expect me
to carry it forever you've been carrying
this for 10 years
and every time your relationship gets a
little bit closer with your sister this
big looming thing is there and here's
the thing
she feels that
yeah she doesn't know what it is and so
what she does she blames herself or she
blames you
she either says i'm still not enough
she's still the golden child she's still
the great because there's that little
gap and kids feel it
you've heard that saying like when
you're driving and you can just turn
your wheel one degree and the whole car
eventually turns in a circle
just that one little feeling as a young
kid that dad likes her more than me what
is it about me do i not look right do i
not smell right do i not hug right what
is it
and i just feel like telling that that's
going to confirm those things to her and
that's but
here's the thing she's been running for
how old is she 35 40 yeah she's 35.
for 35 years she thought it was her
she thought she was the defect
yeah yeah and what you may give yes this
thing's going to go nuclear make no
mistake has she been an addict
um
no i'm i i she
um like as far as like drugs go she's
tried to she doesn't like the way they
make her feel i think she has some um
maybe some she's on the autism spectrum
why are you
why are you
keeping her kid
uh um motherhood didn't work um and i'm
not it was it feels like forever ago my
son is eight now um but she she tried to
raise her two oldest girls and um she
had a very hard time with it it's
they're both all three kids are from
three different men
and she didn't commit to any kind of
relationship with any of the men and
then when she found out she was pregnant
again um my mom and my dad
um
encouraged her to let them raise her
girls and then she asked my husband and
i um we had a two-year-old at the time
and they asked us if you know we would
raise
him and we were
we were more than happy to do that so
imagine a place you would have to be
to call somebody who you've lived in
their shadow your whole life
and said
will you take my baby
can you even imagine that i can't even
wrap my head around that
yeah and that's what she's had to do so
you've got this woman
who lives in
24 she bathes in shame
and is reaching out for connection every
all i said we tell your sister all day
long here's i think as a as just basic
human dignity she deserves the truth
yeah and i will tell you the
conversation will be had
it will be
which person's gonna have the courage to
do it and where is this nuclear bomb
gonna go off
if i'm you i would tell my mom i cannot
keep your lie a secret anymore
i refuse to i won't even say i can't
because that makes it sound like it's
out of my control nope i am making a
grown-up choice
i refuse to keep your lie anymore
and what mom's gonna say is oh you're
gonna blow up everything and the
response is no
you blew it up 35 years ago
yeah and i'm not doing this anymore
because i'm a liar and i refuse to lie
on your behalf any longer i'm not going
to do it i'm teaching young kids about
integrity and doing what's right and we
don't keep secrets in this family and i
love you this is how family treats each
other
but by the way i'm over here with mom
yeah
and i just it's no more and
there will be a nuclear fallout here and
you will sleep better than you slept in
10 years
is that fair
yeah
so i would tell my mom
you've got 20 days you've got two 14
days you've got two weeks to have this
conversation
and by the way you will not do this over
text
you'll do an in-person conversation
well
we all live in different states hey this
is a conversation you get on an airplane
yeah
to say 35 years of your life has been a
lie
yeah and your inability to hold a
relationship your inability to feel like
you are worth anything
maybe
because we lied to you
from the day you were born
yeah
yeah that's a get on an airplane that's
i don't have the money figure it out
we're gonna do this one in person
and you're going to show up with
pictures here is your real dad here's
his name here's where he lives
and he tells me that she doesn't know
that
not true when she told me but
i got the kind of indication and feeling
that that wasn't true we found osama bin
laden he can be found
he can be found i think that's what my
mom has always been worried about that
she would just go searching for her
actually she should when we were her
she should go find her dad
yes
yes
she's 35.
who we protect
who are we protecting what is our
protection got us
yeah
we've been trying to protect and look at
the life that's just in ash
she's got three beautiful kids that
don't even live with her anymore
yeah she's got no close relationships
and nobody's drawn the line back to day
one when we lied to her the day she was
born
yeah
and so all this
if you were protecting her and she had a
wonderful four kids and a great partner
and an awesome job as a surgeon and a
you know just running a small business
and life was great
and you were like man we gotta tell her
the truth i get i get how hard that
would be you still gotta do the right
thing but i get like we're about to take
a norman rockwell painting and set it on
fire i get that
yeah but y'all are protected it's like
her life isn't like that at all no no
it's like y'all are trying to protect
her from a fire and you put her in the
middle of the fire pit
all right no more fight nobody tell her
that there's fire she's burned to a
crisp she gets it and so i'm telling you
what you already know i
secrets destroy families and by the way
your relationship with your mom is
fractured over this
yes your relationship with your dad is
fractured over this
because you there's a part there's a
little girl in you that doesn't trust
them either
yeah
and you have probably made some
commitments to your kids that i will
never but you got this big one hovering
over and you gotta deal with it so i
give mom you got two weeks to do an
in-person conversation or i'm getting on
an airplane and i'm going to fly to be
with my sister and i'm going to have a
hard conversation
real hard okay i can do that okay now
hear me say
this goes bad
it goes bad
yeah
and you can send me an email on the
flight home and be like that son of a i
hate to loan that guy i'm telling you it
goes bad
in your soul you know this is right
yes i do yes is your husband with you
uh yes well he's not here with me i know
but is he all in
yes he and so do my brothers they
understand they they feel like i'm about
to why why am i about to blow up her
world but i agree with you it's already
a mess it's over yeah
you are gonna
possibly
give her the first
glimpse of light through the cracks of
her life that she's ever seen
yeah
and being able to look her in the eye
and say i need you to hear me say i
you're not crazy
yeah and
she has a right to be
enraged
because for the last 35 years this has
been her fault her problems
and they are she's made bad choices
let's be clear
but my guess is my gut tells me she has
been in search for some for true
connection since the day she was born
and she's been looking over and over and
over and over for it
this might be the first real
conversation she's ever had in her life
marie ever ever ever and god bless you
for having him
but yeah no more secrets no more secrets
no more secrets mom you got seven days
and then i'm getting on a plane
that one's gonna be tough
that one's gonna be tough
i'm glad you're there marie go make that
call